we got a call from the hey I'm saying oh
you know what if you don't come back
forget your password ticking away I'm
standing at the very top of the
headquarter building here at education
city a huge campus that was built 20
years ago by subletter foundation now
this place is home to some of the best
branch campuses in the world such as
Georgetown Texas A&M and Northwestern I
go to Georgetown and we go to see you
guys yeah we know Jennifer and what was
it like for you princess silver edge of
the stories because I have a brother
Bruce's in Jordan they are complete
lookit my brother are most opposed to to
come to offer and to go through behind
has planted so we're worried about his
side they're always good with speeches
very normal but I think after the second
third fourth day we realized okay this
is very serious what are we really gonna
do we still don't know it's the third
week now for me personally it's been
basically business as usual what about
that first day or two when you heard the
news of diplomatic ties being cut I
think it was more of the the drama of
the whole situation of the announcement
you know you woke up one morning and
three or four different countries had
cut off ties with you I feel like it's a
matter of country fighting for hegemony
in the region and it's something that
concerns us and like it's normal
civilians like how much this was
everything was business as usual for us
but politically speaking I think this
has to be sorted out because there'll
members of the GCC and the Gulf
Cooperation Council has been around for
a very long time it's difficult to
process the fact that if they don't
leave within a certain amount of time
they have the passports revoked but in
familiar friendly and we know personally
to people in Georgetown who are Saudi
and we still don't know if they're going
to be continuing their studies here
scene considering social media activity
there has been a lot of bad blood within
the GCC within nationals from different
EPC countries I just think that people
should remember that whatever happens
between government does not have to
affect the population like we are still
the same nothing changed that people are
intermarried there's family
relationships family ties being ruined
tommy ties at risk my does return a my
mom's Qatari
vs. my mom supports in 1999 have lived
completely full custody with my mom so
I've lived here with my mom
so this is my home you feel more
Katyayani
yeah I feel more Qatari since all my
family are here I don't have any
connections with my family back in
behind so it's absurd to say that we
have to go back to a country that just
has like our name basically it's just
that passport we don't have any family
there we don't have a future there all
our family and friends are here we said
yep we got contacted by the behind and
they keep telling us oh we have to go
back are you in touch with your dad do
you feel like there's a possibility that
you will be forced to go to by him I
don't think I can physically be forced
to go to the hand because Qatar here has
given me everything I want and they have
not told for forced any GCC countries or
any country in fact to leave guitar I
don't think I'll forcibly leave although
I've been threatened that I would be
stateless because they threatened that
they would take my passport to life
behind embassy contacted me through my
university a month the phone situation
but didn't explain why what did they
said you a month before the situation so
he contacted me a month before the
situation asking us through the
university for call contact yeah of
every penny in our University and their
full name when I asked for why do they
want to select we don't know they
haven't told us why and I refused to the
field
it felt solid because haven't been in
behind why would they suddenly ask what
do you think of the fact that Tamara and
Saudi are finding citizen for showing
support for thought on Twitter they are
trying to stop people of on having human
emotions you can't sympathize with the
country
you can't simplifies that your family
members who are living in comfort of
knew you can't speak for god knows how
long
because as citizens you want more
information and we're not getting their
information we don't know how long this
quest is going to last and for a
government to come down and tell the
people that you're not allowed to speak
about your family and closet or your
friends or not there was a country's
population in general
something that very evening we're the
only country in this problem right now
that haven't been told not to speak why
do you think this happened is it because
pathetic funding terrorists I don't
think that I don't think that's the
reason that's the reason that they use
to initiate the situation they're using
that as an excuse because they clearly
don't know the reasonable self
I'm personally I'm an expat and I was
born and raised here and I've seen
nothing but good treatment from the
government from the people
[Music]
this time my day as cumbersome crushing
inflated